now we all know for a fact that if you
have constipation you just need to add
more fiber okay I mean it's the general
consensus of the medical community that
a lack of fiber is really what's behind
constipation well today let's just talk
about what the number one mistake is
with constipation and then some
additional things that you need to know
if you have constipation let's just take
a look at constipation for a second it's
a traffic jam in your gut right it's
congestion
you have too much stool now fiber
increases bulk
okay it increases
stool it increases volume so just by
looking at that why would you ever want
to increase more volume or mass
or bulk into a tube or Plumbing that's
already congested
that does not make sense to me also
think about what fiber does
it causes your microbes to create
fermentation with fermentation comes gas
and bloating usually people that have
constipation don't need any more gas or
bloating the other point about people
that are chronically constipated is that
they're already doing a lot of fiber but
it's not working so to add more fiber
it's not a good idea there's some
fascinating studies with people who have
both chronic constipation and people who
have constipation with irritable bowel
syndrome or some other type of
inflammatory condition that adding more
fiber will make it worse that's right if
you have sibo small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth
which is your microbes are in the wrong
place they're in the small intestine
okay they should be in the large
intestine so they're higher up and you
consume more fiber oh my goodness are
you going to get bloating it's going to
make things really really bad so the
biggest mistake that people make for
constipation is adding more fiber in
fact I used to have very very bad
constipation and by accident I got rid
of it it was at the time when
I kind of stumbled on
cutting out carbs and so I was doing a
lot of grain carbs as my fiber for
cereal and things like that when I
switched to eating more
like Meats like a buffalo burger or even
even fish for breakfast
all my constipation completely went away
and it was like I was dumbfounded
because I'm like I just thought I had to
add more Metamucil or other types of
fiber but every time I did that it got
worse but it was really bizarre just to
eat more meat and find that my
constipation completely cleared up but
at the time I didn't really know why so
instead of adding more fiber just omit
the fiber so number one reduce your
fiber now of course I just want to
differentiate two different types of
fiber okay
vegetable fiber is usually okay but even
that sometimes can bind you up but the
most likely reason for people having a
worsening with more fiber is the grain
fiber and that includes the fiber from
Beans lentils and bran and unfortunately
now even the keto Community there's all
sorts of new synthetic fibers like corn
fiber and tapioca fiber and all sorts of
things that are I think very unhealthy
but we won't go there on this video all
right number two is the side effect from
their medication and acids
antidepressants are common medications
that have side effects of constipation
but there are others as well so I always
like to kind of look at the obvious
what's the elephant in the room and if
someone's doing medication like just
look that up and see if it has a side
effect of constipation now the next
thing is a lack of thymine vitamin B1 B1
is intimately involved involved in the
What's called the peristalsis or the
pumping action of the colon because it
helps build up what's called a
neurotransmitter called acetylcholine
and so the reason why people are
deficient in B1 is that they consume too
many carbs and sugars but B1 can
sometimes easily correct constipation
plus it supports the vagus nerve which
is part of the autonomic nervous system
which actually can really help if
someone has like too much stress too and
their everything is locked up because
they're more in this flight or fight
mode so that would be another reason
stress okay stress is a part of that as
well now the next one is a lack of bile
if you're lacking bile typically you
will have constipation
bile tends to lubricate the colon and
sometimes people have like this bile
sludge that's bound up into the bile
ducts and that can cause pain in the
right shoulder or or discomfort or
tightness underneath the right rib cage
which is indication that they don't have
enough bile by adding more bile salts is
a supplement you can sometimes relieve
constipation and even get rid of
constipation because it helps to
lubricate the colon and also helps you
digest but I want to bring it up as a a
definite cause to constipation if you
take too much bile you'll get diarrhea
so that's a good way to know if you're
taking too much bile the other thing is
that dysbiosis this is a involving
imbalance in your microflora and your
gut so instead of adding more fiber why
don't you just add more of a probiotic
right that would be a a better thing to
do because the microbes in constipation
a lot of times are are missing but if
you have sibo which is small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth
if you take these microbes okay they end
up in the small intestine and that can
actually give you more bloating so if
you get more bloating with
probiotics then we know you might have
sibo another common cause of
constipation is the person's eating too
many frequent meals they're having three
meals three snacks and you never let
your digestive system have a chance to
breathe or rest in between eating so
going on an intermittent fasting
schedule is huge it's a game changer for
someone that has chronic constipation
because you finally have a chance to let
your digestive system rest in between
eating it's not natural to eat of that
frequency another thing is sometimes
when people eat way too much protein
sometimes they go on Carnivore and they
get constipated they need to increase
more fat to their protein ratios because
if they have too much protein you can
only digest or or assimilate so much
protein and the rest can be a problem
and sometimes it can be constipating
that's why like on the Atkins diet which
is a high protein diet you know one of
the side effects is constipation versus
the healthy version of Keto that I
recommend it's a moderate amount of
protein and then the other thing that's
connected to that is low hydrochloric
acid if you don't have enough HCL in
your stomach you're not going to be able
to digest protein and that is going to
cause constipation because you're going
to have incomplete digestion at a higher
level so you have this huge tube that's
like 25 feet long if you can't digest
way up at the top of the tube think
about what happens lower in the chain of
events you get a lot of undigested food
material that just backs up as a traffic
jam
so adding betaine hydrochloride apple
cider vinegar when you eat is a very
smart thing the other thing is like
you're very low in magnesium and
potassium you have two electrolytes that
are needed
um to power these little
um batteries that power the nerves and
the muscle and your colon is muscle so
it needs potassium and magnesium as the
electrolytes and also magnesium
creates a nice relaxation of the muscle
so of course if you have too much you
can create diarrhea but anyway I wanted
to touch on this topic of constipation
to give you some additional things to
think about and do and if you have not
seen my video on intermittent fasting
that would be probably one of the most
important things to do if you have not
started yet and I put that video up
right here